>> Hello my name's Katina Johnson, and it's
my pleasure to host and
introduce the Reverend Scotty McLennan on
behalf of Authors@Google and
he's also brought his family.
So, um, the Reverend McLennan is a dean for
Religious Life at Stanford.
From 1984 to 2000, he was the University Chaplain
at Tufts.
And also a Senior Lecturer at the Harvard
Business School for ten of
those years.
Reverend McLennan received his BA from Yale
in 1970 working in the
areas of computers and the mind and he received
his Masters of Divinity
and JD degrees from Harvard Divinity and Law
Schools in 1975.
And that was the year that he also became
an ordained Unitarian
Universalist Minister and was admitted to
the Massachusetts bar as an
attorney.
He's the author of Finding Your Religion.
And the book that he's here today to discuss,
Jesus was a Liberal,
Reclaiming Christianity for All.
On his bio and the list of accomplishments
-- this is an aside,
what caught my eye and really made me say
cool, is that he was one of
the inspirations for Doonebury's the Reverend
Scott Sloan, so I was
thought it was a nice little fun fact.
But going back to his book today, Reclaiming
Christianity addresses
topics such as intelligent design, abortion,
same sex marriage, war and
torture which are all are really hotbed topics.
And in a time where religion and politics
are intertwined, and a
climate where the media views christian and
liberal as mutually
exclusive, it's refreshing to have Reverend
McLennan here to advocate
for, as he says in his book, a sense of religion
based not on doctrinal
readings of scripture but on the humanity
behind Christ's teaching.
So please join me in welcoming the Reverend
Scotty McLennan.
SCOTTY McLENNAN: Thanks very much Katina and
thank you all for coming.
It's a real pleasure to be here at Google.
And to have an opportunity to talk about this
book in this environment.
It's been interesting going around the country
talking about it in a
variety of different contexts.
I must say some of them have been very receptive
and others not so
much.
When I was San Diego, I needed to go to four
different venues before I
was actually allowed to speak.
And that was surprising, I think, you know,
that when you say, Jesus
was a liberal, it's a little provocative.
But that provocative that you -- only a public
library was finally
allow me to speak.
In Texas, where it was a wonderful opportunity
at the largest
independent bookseller in America, where they
were very -- they had a
great crowd, very nice introduction.
But as I introduced, the person from the bookstore
said, this book
is -- the title is clearly toxic, but -- and
then went on to say he's
an interesting character.
You should listen up.
And on the other hand, in Washington D.C.,
I found that a lot of the
people responding from Capitol Hill, from
the political environment of
Washington D.C., felt that I was going too
far in trying to promote
some role for religion in the public -- public
arena.
And I've had a number of critiques from atheists,
from the
neo-atheists, about why we should be talking
about religion at all in
the 21st century, especially given all the
damage that is done in the
name of religion throughout the world.
I also appreciate you mentioning, Katina,
that there's Reverend Scott
Sloan character in Doonesbury, red-haired,
red-bearded as I was once,
30 years ago, when my college roommate Garry
Trudeau created the strip
and put a loot of his roommates in the strip.
And they didn't say in those days when you
went to college, when you
were asked whether you wanted a roommate that
smoked or was going to be
up late at night or go to bed early, they
didn't say anything about
have the risks of having a cartoonist as a
roommate.
And having this caricature go on for the rest
of your life, so that you
become a lifelong joke.
But I do stand here with some seriousness
as well today to talk about
this book.
And Garry, of course, pushed me the other
way as well.
And he has this very nice word -- these words
on the cover which say,
"It's a timely and powerfully reasoned argument,
that it's time for
liberals to reclaim ownership of Christ as
he was, a outlier, a
passionate but rationalist revolutionary who
spoke to the best in us."
So I number of people have come at me the
other way, saying, "Jesus was
a liberal?
Jesus was a radical.
Jesus was a revolutionary why are you making
this so pallid?"
So what I'd like to do is to spend a little
time reading to you from
the book, and giving you a sense of what I'm
saying in the book and how
I'm saying it.
And then have plenty of time for Q&A because
that's what I think is
most interesting and engaging.
So let me give you a little bit of the flavor
of the book first here.
I say early on that when I'm talking about
liberals, what I mean is a
dictionary definition of liberalism as including:
Belief in progress,
tolerance, individual freedom, and the essential
goodness of humanity.
So those four criteria.
And I believe that Jesus was a religious liberal
because he came with a
fresh, new, progressive vision proclaiming
again and again -- you've
heard that it was said to those of ancient
times, something or other,
but I tell you, and then he had a new vision.
Instead an eye for an eye, he asked us to
turn the other cheek.
Instead of loving just our neighbors, we were
called upon to love our
enemies, too.
He spoke of a New Testament distinct from
the Old Testament that came
before.
Jesus was not a fundamentalist in the sense
of being a Biblical
literalist, he would break one of the Ten
Commandments when he thought
it was the most humane thing to do as when
he worked healing people on
the Sabbath.
He as clearly said the Sabbath was made for
humankind and not humankind
for the Sabbath.
Then I go on to say early in the book that
I am a liberal Christian and
so are a large number of American Christians
according to sociologists
of religion.
We've been called progressive Christians,
we're generally found in main
line as distinct from evangelical churches.
Unfortunately, we're often either forgotten
or maligned in the current
culture wars and public debates between the
Religious Right and the
Secular Left.
And by the way, as an aside, I really did
write this book because the
press continually talks about the Religious
Right versus the Secular
Left.
And there are a lot of us in between, a lot
of us who are religious.
And this book was written for Christians,
but I also -- when I say
Reclaiming Christianity for All as a subtitle
of the book, I'm hoping
to present Christianity in a way that will
be inclusive and open to
people of other traditions or no tradition
at all as well as to
Christians from conservatives to liberals.
But I go on to say that we are the Religious
Left, not the Religious
Right.
But what do we stand for?
Not all of us share exactly the same perspective,
of course, nor would
we all accept each description in the next
paragraph, but we tend to be
identifiable by many of the following principles:
First, the Bible is meant to be read largely
metaphorically and
allegorically rather than literally.
Science and religion are compatible.
We are committed to the use of logic, reason,
and the Scientific
Method.
Doubt is the handmaiden of faith.
Love is the primary Christian value, and it's
directly related to the
promotion of liberty and justice in society
at large.
All people are inherently equal and worthy
of dignity and respect.
Free religious expression should be governmentally
protected but no
particular tradition should be established
as the State Religion.
There are many roads to the top of the spiritual
mountain and
Christianity is only one of them.
Interfaith understanding and tolerance are
critical.
We see Jesus primarily as a spiritual and
ethic teacher and less as
being identical with God.
Living a fulfilled and ethical life here and
now is more important than
speculating on what happens to us after we
die.
Nonviolence is strongly preferred in relationships
between human
beings, groups, and nations.
Women and men must play an equal role in religious
leadership.
And in terms of current American hot-button
issues, we tend to be
pro-choice on abortion and in favor of marriages
for same sex couples.
And then I go on and talk a little bit about
various people
historically who have been liberal Christians.
I actually relate this tradition back to the
very beginning.
Arius, who was one of the original church
fathers -- it wasn't until it
wasn't until 325 of the common era, 300 years
after the birth and death
of Christ, that decided in the Christian church
that Jesus was
identical with God.
And a number of people have picked up on the
tradition, the early
tradition in the church after the Protestant
Reformation.
And I mention some of them here, some of whom
who were burned at the
stake like Marcos -- Michael Servetus in the
16th century; some like
Galileo, that were forced to renounce their
scientific discoveries.
But others like John lock who faired better
and had considerable
influence on the Christian founders, liberal
Christian founders of the
United States in the 18th century like Thomas
Jefferson, Benjamin
Franklin, and Abigail and John Adams.
And I mentioned that even the liberal Christians
of the 19th century in
America like Ralph Waldo Emerson and Susan
B. Anthony met with strong
public outcries of disgust for their religious
belief with the rise
fundamentalism in the 20th century, liberals
were often condemned as
enemies of the cross of Christ, and accused
of apostasy.
But then I go on to say that ironically, the
strong denunciation of
liberal Christianity, a strong denunciation
of liberal Christianity is
coming from another quarter in the early 21st
century, from public
atheists in Europe and America such as scientists
Richard Dawkins and
Sam Harris, philosopher Dan Dennett -- when
I was at Tufts University
for 16 years as the University Chaplain, Dan
Dennett was a professor
there, we used to have lunch together and
talk about these issues.
I actually thought he was a closet Buddhist
but he never accepted that.
But, anyway, philosopher Dan Dennett, journalist
Christopher Hitchens,
who published bestselling books with such
titles as The God Delusion;
the End of Faith; Breaking the Spell; and
God is not Great.
Today, the estimated 60 million liberal Christians
in America are
caught in the crossfire between the Secular
Left and the Religious
Right.
While outspoken atheists like Richard Dawkins
called God a delusion and
back up their claim with compelling arguments,
well-known conservatives
like Ann Coulter, the author of Godless, the
Church of Liberalism, take
aim with damming charges.
Everything liberals believe is in elegant
opposition to basic Biblical
precepts, what's a liberal Christian to do?
So, um, as Katina appoints out, I talk about
a lot of different parts
of Christianity in the book.
There's a chapter on the essence of Christianity
which as I mentioned,
I believe to be love but I try to spell you
that out in quite a bit of
detail.
I have chapters on God, Jesus, the Bible,
the Church, and on faith --
what is faith?
And then a chapter on talking to atheists
and Christian conservatives,
how to try to do that effectively.
There's a whole section of the book on all
of the social issues that
were mentioned from science and religion,
intelligent design, abortion,
same sex marriage, war, poverty, bigotry,
torture, environmental
issues, and so on.
Church and state as well.
And then a section of the book on Christian
doctrine, issues like the
trinity.
What does it mean to have a triune God of
a father, son, and Holy
Spirit?
Communion, the central sacrament of the Christian
church.
Being born-again, what does it mean to have
had a born-again
experience?
The apocalypse, a lot being said, a lot of
bestselling books on -- that
we're at the end time here, and some of us
will make it and most of us
won't.
And the Sabbath.
What is the Sabbath?
And what has it been historically?
And why should we set a day apart in the week
where we actually rest?
Which I'm sure you all do a wonderful day
a week here at Google.
And then the church year: I talk about Advent
and Christmas, Holy
Week, and Easter.
And then I have a conclusion at the end of
the book.
And I'd like to read you a little bit from
that.
[Reading]
"In the fall before the 2008 election, the
editor of the 125-year old
publication Christian Century wrote, 'in the
theological arena, liberal
has become such a negative term that few want
to use it.'
And that's a discouraging conclusion from
the journal that's probably
been the most effective voice for liberal
Christianity for over a
century.
Early in the 20th century, the magazine was
a primary target of the new
fundamentalist movement. And by mid-century,
Billy Graham helped found
a new magazine of evangelical conviction to
oppose it called
Christianity Today.
But now the editor of the Christian Century
tells us that liberal
Christianity it living in exile and that liberal
Christians prefer to
use other words to describe themselves like
progressive.
And may be partly a result of the political
implications of the word
liberal.
I happened to be listening to the radio in
September 2008, when a
conservative Christian named Mitt Romney was
speaking to the Republican
Convention in support of John McCain and Sarah
Palin.
I counted more than a dozen times that he
pejoratively used the word
liberal or liberals.
He claimed that liberals are responsible for
awarding Guantanamo
terrorists with Constitutional Rights, putting
the interests of the
teachers' union ahead of the needs of our
children, stopping nuclear
power plants and offshore drilling, making
us more and more dependent
on Middle Eastern tyrants and replacing opportunity
with dependency on
government largesse.
And there are a lot of other ways that he
insisted that liberals have
allegedly harmed our country.
Hearing Mitt Romney reminded me of how Michael
Dukakis, the liberal
governor of Massachusetts, was said to have
lost the 1988 election to
George H.W. Bush because he was shackled by
the L word by Republicans.
Worse perhaps, he refused to defend what was
positive about liberalism,
even claiming in an interview with television
commentator Ted Koppel,
two weeks before the election, "Ted, I'm not
a liberal."
In Washington -- I mean that was ridiculous.
Michael Dukakis?
He was really high ADA rating and so on.
It was a really low moment I thought.
But anyway.
A Washington Post article in this early 2008
explained that Barack
Obama was independently ranked at the most
liberal United States
Senator in 2007.
Then the Post editor predicted that in the
lead-up to the election, he
would keep trying to claim that he's post-partisan,
not liberal.
Even though John McCain, in his own way, was
post-partisan before the
term was invented often working across the
aisle on important
legislation defying party orthodoxy far more
than Obama had.
The Washington Post article ended with these
words: The only democrats
who have won the White House in the last four
decades have done so by
running away from the liberal label, and Obama
is certainly a student
of history.
By contrast, the Christian Century editor
claimed that liberalism is an
important thread in the political fabric of
our history.
He pointed out that the founders of the Republic
were enlightenment
thinkers, in part, in large part philosophically
and theologically
liberal.
The liberal impulse in American politics is
responsible for social
security, Medicare and Medicaid, head start,
and food stamps.
Liberals, often in the face of fierce conservative
opposition, have
been the ones to guarantee equal rights.
And they've made laws that help keep our food
and automobiles safe and
college education affordable.
Liberal Christianity can point to the Old
Testament prophets and to
Jesus as the original political liberals.
As mainstream a resource at the Encyclopedia
Britannica describes
political liberalism as the culmination of
a development that goes back
to the Hebrew prophets, the teachings of the
Pre-Socratic philosophers
and the Sermon on the Mount of Jesus of Nazareth.
All right.
I'm trying finish up here so we can get to
some discussion.
Let me give you just another page or so here.
Jesus often asserted that socially despised
tax collectors and
prostitutes will enter the kingdom of God
before esteemed religious
leaders.
The sinful who make spiritual progress take
precedence over the
religiously pure who won't recognize any authority
but their own.
Jesus was known for his commitments to the
outcast and the marginalized
in society, whom we must never forget have
human potential.
Jesus shows himself as tolerant to all sorts
and conditions of people,
as liberals should be, not dogmatic and doctrinal.
Freedom, reason, progress, tolerance -- values
to be proud of, not
ducked because they conjure up the L word.
And let's not forget the dictionary definitions
of liberal as
synonymous with generous, bountiful, open-handed,
munificent, and
abundant.
So what is the future of liberal Christianity?
Of Christianity marked
by commitments to freedom from authority,
the use of reason, human
progress, and tolerance towards others.
There's no future if people aren't willing
to stand up for these values
and claim the label liberal as their own.
Jesus was a liberal in substantial and important
ways.
Christians need to stand up for him in that
respect.
Why has the liberal voice been so muted in
Christianity?
The editor of Christian Century reminds us
that people living in exile
don't get to define the terms of political
discourse.
And I'm quoting him now.
Conservatives have won the rhetorical battle.
He also observes that because tolerance is
one of the central values of
liberals, they don't like to fight.
But instead are always trying to accommodate
people.
To be inclusive even of those who are trying
to exclude them.
And I must admit that defines me to a "T."
The Christian Century editor concludes that
the first thing on the
minds of my conservative brothers and sisters
when they get out of bed
in the morning is fighting liberals, I think
of Mitt Romney and Ann
Coulter as quintessential.
Whereas liberals get out of bed trying to
figure out how to live with
conservatives.
And yes, that's what I do most of the time
especially in my role as
Dean for Religious Life at Stanford, pledge
to meeting the needs of all
faiths by encouraging a widespread spectrum
of religious traditions on
campus, many of them quite conservative.
But tolerance doesn't mean capitulation.
It doesn't mean shying away from expressing
liberal Christian values
that defend the freedom of all, promote the
use of reason, and affirm
the human potential to better ourselves and
help repair a broken world.
There are clear dangers demonstrated throughout
the Bible, and
specifically in the Christian Gospel, of ceding
authority to the
religious establishment, cherishing belief
over reason, accentuating
sin over the human potential for good, and
prioritizing alleged truth
claims over tolerance.
Liberal Christians constitute at least 20
percent of the U.S.
population according to recent studies.
Too many of them choose silence, afraid to
use the word liberal to
describe where they stand.
And that leaves them lying low, sitting quietly
in their pews at
church, or in private prayer at home, or choosing
simply to identify as
political liberals without mentioning their
faith commitments.
They must reclaim their religious heritage
as an independent source of
wisdom, encourage in their personal lives
and in their community
involvements.
To them, and to myself as one of them, I bellow,
stand up, stand tall
and proclaim the positive power of liberal
Christianity and do it now
before it's too late.
That's enough of my reading and preaching.
Let's -- let's hear what you're thinking.
[PAUSE]
>> So I completely agree with the -- the notion
that liberals, you
know, don't seek conflict.
And, um, I'm -- you know, what are we to do
about that?
Stand up and what?
Because I think one of the other things that
I think is common among
liberal Christians is that they -- they don't
seek to proselytize.
SCOTTY McLENNAN: So, I think liberals do have
a very real problem in
both of those respects.
We tend not to be very good at standing up
and proclaiming what we
believe and we don't like to proselytize our
beliefs indeed.
I do think though that we -- we have had a
history, especially when
under fire from either the Religious Right
in risking the -- being
literally burned at the stake, which happened
historically or when we
are, as we are now being attacked often by
the Secular Left, in
particular the neo-atheists who say that liberals
are actually the
worst, because they feel they can deal with
conservative religionists
whose claims will fall of their own weight
eventually.
But liberals provide a kind of rational veneer
that's put over the
damage that religion has done, religious violence,
religious bigotry
and so on and the real enemy are religious
liberals.
So I think if nothing else when you're condemned
that way, it's time to
stand up and react.
What are some of the things that we can do
quite specifically?
I think we have methodologies for engaging
people in dialogue that are
badly needed in a time where you have, basically,
talking heads on
television that are playing hard ball with
each other, and in a time
where our political process is at a level
of incivility that seems
unprecedented.
So if we can create methodologies for people
to actually listen to each
other before they speak and that's part of
the liberal tradition.
I think we can be quite effective.
So a few ideas.
Yeah, I think you need to go to the mike.
>> So I was kind up brought up to be a religious
liberal, but then --
Christian liberal, specifically -- but then
one day I sort of read the
Bible.
And I was kind of shocked cause, on the one
hand, there's some -- what
I see is really good stuff in there, like,
you know, do unto others as
you would have them do unto you, not to be
cliche or anything.
But then there's also stuff in there like
separating the chaff, and you
know, throwing the chaff into the fire, and
I'm not here to I'm not
here to make peace.
I'm here to divide father against son and
brother against whatever, and
a lot of that kind of disturbed me, actually.
And so, you know, I sort of have my own belief
system which is mine and
I'm okay with it.
But I have -- like, I'm curious what your
perspective is on some of
these passages as a theologian number one,
with a liberal outlook, and
number two, how you would go about -- if you
had kids -- well see, you
know that stuff about sending stuff in the
flame, they didn't really
mean that.
SCOTTY McLENNAN: Nice question.
Indeed, there are all kinds of things that
you find in the Bible that
are really repugnant from the perspective
I've been describing.
So you point out that although Jesus says
blessed are the peacemakers
and he talks about turning the other cheek,
and he seems to have a very
loving perspective in so many ways, he does
say at another point, I
come not to bring peace but a sword, and divide
brother from sister and
parent from child and so on.
So what do we do with those kinds of difficult
texts?
You look at his talking about peace and then
look at the whole story of
the Exodus that Christians build on.
You have Joshua going into Jericho to fight
the battle against the
Canaanites who were then in possession of
the land, and not only do the
walls of Jericho come tumbling down, and all
the soldiers are killed by
Joshua and his Israelite troops but also are
women and children and
elderly are killed and all of the cattle are
killed then everything is
burned to the ground.
So what do we do with those realities?
Now the truth is, and you see this happening
for Islam now, for the
Qur'an, and you see it happening actually
with the -- in the Hindu
tradition with the Bhagavad Gita and so on.
You could pick out these proof texts for virtually
anything you want in
religion.
And so, although Gandhi used the Bhagavad
Gita as the basis for his
whole movement of nonviolence, himsa, if you
read that carefully,
you'll see that it's Argena, the warrior,
going to Krishna, God, and
saying, do I really have to go out on the
battlefield and kill my
relatives who are on the other side?
And Krishna says, yes, you do.
That's your dharma; that's your duty.
And you have to do it with no personal attachment.
You have to do it in a non-attached way.
Now how Gandhi can then use that as a basis
for talking about
nonviolence is tricky.
But in fact, what he said is that's an internal
battle that we all go
through between our own, in effect, demons
and angels.
The notion of Jihad in the Qur'an, also, it's
primary meaning is the
internal struggle that we each go through
between our bad and good
selves and so on and some of that imagery
is helpful because these are
real struggles that we go through.
There are evil in the world.
There are -- there is human sinfulness that
all of us are part of and
we do have genuine struggles.
But I do actually work with some of the passages
that you mentioned in
the text of my book and try to help us understand
that it really -- I
don't think to pick out those few proof texts,
really helps us
understand the essence of who Jesus was.
Jesus really was somebody who came with this
new message of peace, of
love, and you need to look at the whole rather
than grabbing a proof
text here and a proof text there.
Although, I'm often criticized as a liberal,
for picking -- cherry
picking the liberal texts.
But when you look at the sweep of the New
Testament and the sweep of
what Jesus came to do, I think again and again
you'll see he came for
the marginalized, for the poor, he stood up
for those who were
oppressed.
He had new visions of love and tolerance.
His great, um, you mentioned the sort of cliches
of the Golden Rule and
so on.
But the Good Samaritan story is a really impressive
story because --
and Samaritans used to be hated non-Jews.
They weren't part of Jesus' tradition, so
when he asked, who is my
neighbor?
He reaches out and tells a story about people
from his own religious
tradition leaving this bloody guy on the side
of the road while the
person who came to help was a non-Jew, a hated
foreigner called a
Samaritan.
So this kind of reaching out that Jesus did,
even beyond his own
religious tradition to valorize somebody of
another religious tradition
I think is pretty impressive.
[PAUSE]
>> Hi.
So my question kind of relates to the last
one.
So I'm just curious what is your general view
of scripture, especially
the New Testament, it is, like how do you
know which parts to -- are
true and which aren't?
And, like, do you kind of view it all as having
been mistranslated or,
like, is it as an accurate representation
of what actually happened or
not?
And if not, which, like, which parts are and
which aren't and how do
you know?
SCOTTY McLENNAN: No, I think we need to take
the entirety of the New
Testament seriously.
We need to work with it, study it, try to
figure out who wrote it, why,
under what circumstances.
The New Testament was written from about 50
of the Common Era to
20 years after Jesus died until about 100
of the Common Era.
And a lot of different historical contexts
before and after the
destruction of the Temple in Jerusalem in
70 A.D. or of the Common Era,
by people of different parts the ancient Mid-East
who were having a
variety of different kinds of struggles both
within their communities
and with people around them.
We have Paul going out to the Gentile world,
because Christianity was
originally a Jewish sect, and Jesus -- I'm
crystal clear from
everything he wrote -- always considered himself
a Jew, assumed he was
a Jew, assumed he was going to reform Judaism.
He didn't think he was starting a new religion.
So you have all of these, and you do have
the Christian church
developing, and then reinterpreting the scriptures
in relation to their
new understanding, and then we go through
2000 years of
reinterpretation of who Jesus was based on
the scripture, et cetera.
So it's an active, vital text that people
continue to work with in a
variety of ways.
But we absolutely need to take every word
of the New Testament
seriously.
I use the Christian Lectionary to preach from
that is a three-year
cycle, where all Christian churches, ideally,
are using the same
lessons from the Gospels, from the letters
of Paul, from Psalms, and
from the Old Testament or the Hebrew bible,
every Sunday and that's a
really good discipline, because there's the
text.
The text for this week may be, I come not
to bring peace but a sword.
I need to go to my commentaries and need to
find out what's meant in
the original languages.
I need to see what the context was and then
bring that up to today and
say, what's the message for today?
So, absolutely, we need to take all of it
seriously and we need to deal
with the reality of what may be hard texts.
I was actually quite surprised recently taking
with some evangelical
friends, who in Bible churches, where I assumed
they used the
Lectionary as the discipline that I do.
They said, oh, no. We don't use the Lectionary,
what do you do?
It's a Bible church, you're presumably teaching
the Bible.
Well, there are certain passages that are
important to us and we spend
our time emphasizing, and we don't really
get on overview of the -- of
the New Testament or the Bible as a whole.
That was quite surprising to me.
Why should a liberal be the one who's trying
to look at the entire
tradition and take it all very seriously,
while evangelical, Bible
churches are saying, well, we don't actually
read the whole Bible.
>> And then, so, just to clarify -- so what's
your kind of view on
Jesus?
Do you think he was divine or not?
And he was -- did he -- was he resurrected
from the dead or not?
SCOTTY McLENNAN: Okay, divinity of Jesus and
the resurrection, two
small questions.
[LAUGHTER]
So let me see if I can do that justice quickly.
No, I don't believe that Jesus was divine
in the sense of being
identical with God.
I do think he was a person filled with the
spirit of God and was very
high, spiritually speaking.
He was one of the great prophets, one of the
great teachers.
We look at other people in world religions
like the Buddha or Krishna,
if he was in fact a historical person, but
others and other
incarnations.
In the Hindu traditions, like Ramakrishna
of the 19th century and so
on.
Mohammed, other major prophets who spoke for
God and were filled with
the spirit of God.
I don't think Jesus, if you look at the text
of the New Testament
carefully, thought he was God.
In fact, there are times where he said don't
call me teacher.
You have only one teacher or master and that
is God.
Or in the garden of Gethsemane near the end
of his life, when he
realized what he was facing in terms of possible
execution, he said,
God, please take this task from me.
And he prayed in the garden.
And then ultimately at the end of it he said,
well I understand, it's
not my will, but it's your will to be done.
So again and again it seems to me, Jesus -- I
think he would have
thought it was idolatrous, honestly, to imagine
himself as identical
with God.
He did come, he told us again and again with
the very special message
from God about the eminent coming of the Kingdom
of God, breaking into
the world, what that meant, what kind of ethics
we should have and live
in in relation to that.
Now we come to the resurrection.
Jesus, in his last week of life went into
the Temple in Jerusalem,
overturned the money changers tables.
This was part of the -- the ritual that was
used in the Temple where
animals were sacrificed and you needed to
have your money changed from
Roman coinage into proper sacrificial coinage
in order to buy these
sacrificial animals and so on.
But the Gospel of John tells us that Jesus
drove the money changers out
with whips, that he drove all the animals
out.
I mean this is a violent response from a generally
nonviolent guy.
And he was executed within a week of that
by the Roman Empire, which I
don't think could stand that kind of disruption
at the central ritual
place in their colony during the Jewish Passover.
And certainly, the religious authorities were
very concerned about what
this meant.
So he dies, I believe his disciples, as we
have evidence of, they
betray him, they say we don't know this guy
and go away.
And subsequently, this very discouraged movement
starts to have
experiences of Jesus actually appearing to
them.
The appearances to the disciples are quite
powerful stories.
And then you have people who never knew Jesus
like Paul, who were
struck from horse, some say a epileptic fit,
but he says I was -- had
this experience of Jesus talking to me directly
and telling me what to
do.
And his -- as that happened with Paul, all
those people around him
didn't hear Jesus but Paul did.
Similarly, there were people in the Biblical
accounts walking with
Jesus for a whole day who were his disciples
who didn't recognize him
until the very end when he was breaking bread
at the table and then
just as they recognized him, he disappears.
He moved through walls apparently and would
appear and disappear, if we
read those accounts.
So for me, there are accounts of appearances
but not of a physical,
resuscitated body.
Although, there are some claims as well in
the Gospel accounts of that,
especially of Thomas of putting his fingers
through his hands to make
sure that this is really the physical resuscitated
body.
But the main emphasis I think of those stories
are of appearances.
Now the Christian church then took this very
seriously, this little
Jewish movement took off like wildfire and
not just in Jewish circles
but across the Gentile world as well.
Because Jesus literally lived for people,
and the power of who he was
and what he meant became a very powerful force.
And so in that sense, yes, Jesus was resurrected
for the centuries and
this religious movement has grown and gone
where it's gone.
But I don't personally believe that it was
on the basis of a
resuscitated body.
But on the sense of the appearances of Jesus
and the power that he then
had for this new church as it grew.
Somebody behind you.
>> Hi.
Comment, I think this Jesus may not have considered
himself as God but
I think he -- at least there are a lot of
indications that he clearly
considered himself as the Messiah which is
slightly different.
Anyway, my question is entirely about something
else which is the
political traditions of religious people,
of Christians in particular,
seem to depend on which denominations they
belong to.
Like if you're Baptist or something, then
you're conservative, or
evangelical, you're conservative, or if you're
Episcopalian or
Unitarian, then you are liberal.
And then there are churches like the Catholic
Church, for example, that
are traditionally conservative on reproductive
rights but on the other
hand, John Paul came out strongly against
the war in Iraq.
So are the Baptists recently coming out, well,
not coming out formally
but there's way lot of talk against Proposition
8 here, for example.
My question is really as a Christian, do you
really have to worry about
whether Jesus was liberal or conservative?
I mean, is that really an issue?
Shouldn't you worry more about what Jesus
really was?
And then whether you are following, you know
-- or Jesus, and you know,
maybe conservatives have some of it, maybe
liberals have some of it.
Does it really matter?
I mean, this is your spiritual side of things,
right?
You should worry about Jesus and not really
try to interpret him in
modern political terms.
It's my opinion.
SCOTTY McLENNAN: I think that's a very well-stated
point.
I agree, I think, with all that you say, yes,
we should be following
and trying to understand Jesus as he was and
as he lives for us now.
To use political terms liberal or conservative
is achronistic in many
ways, not -- and if you think you're just
using it as a political
label, it's completely misleading because
Jesus, his work and his life
certainly has had political implications,
and you point out what some
of them are in the modern world, but he is
a spiritual person, a
spiritual leader, somebody who did come as
the Messiah with a new
vision for Israel.
And that's what we need to follow, that's
what we need to understand.
However, the other side of this is that these
terms do get used, and
misused whether we like it or not .
And I want to reclaim the world liberal not
necessarily politically,
although that's important as well, as I mentioned.
But theologically, because there is a long,
strong tradition of liberal
Christianity and that term has been used -- you
go to your Encyclopedia
Britannica and you Christianity, liberal,
and there's an entry.
So I want to reclaim that tradition and talk
about what it stood for,
for tolerance, for the use of reason, for
a progressive vision of
moving towards the future and not just one
of trying to conserve what
came before of an understanding of humans'
ability to rise above and
transcend themselves not just to be mired
forever in Original Sin and
so on and so forth.
So these are theological concepts that are
really countered by a lot of
evangelical or conservative or particularly
fundamentalist Christianity
which sees the world very differently, and
often emphasizes issues like
doctrinal truth over love, which emphasizes
faith and taking a leap of
faith or blind faith over reason and using
reason as one of your
methodologies and so on.
So I really want to emphasize those theological
dimensions when I use
the word liberal.
>> So that -- I had a similar question.
But just to clarify are you -- you started
out saying that Jesus as a
liberal was the denotation of the word as
open, as bucking the
tradition.
So are you ascribing -- are you saying that
Jesus also politically is a
liberal, like, were if -- in terms of what
he believed was -- he passes
the liberal litmus tests?
SCOTTY McLENNAN: No.
I'm not saying that Jesus -- in terms of what
we -- our modern
definition of political liberalism, no.
Because, in fact, the modern definition of
political liberalism has
changed dramatically itself over a couple
hundred years.
I mean, when we talk about the Liberal Arts
in universities or we talk
about the liberal philosophical tradition,
especially, if you go to
Europe now, and you ask to learn about somebody
who is labelled a
liberal, in America, those are what we call
conservatives.
They stand for free markets, the preeminence
of private property, of
limited government and so on.
So the liberal tradition when it started,
those were its values.
Liberals were very concerned about tyranny
about the government being
too powerful, the importance of private property,
the importance of
individualism and so on.
What happened was liberalism evolved politically
so that there's now a
greater concern of what corporate power can
mean than what -- what
government power can mean.
So some of the shift was where is the authority
that we're both worried
about?
So a lot of modern liberals are more worried
about corporate power and
now global corporate power than they are about
governmental power.
And they begin to use some of the governmental
structures to try to
counter what they see to be the frightening
use of authoritarianism.
So, no, I really don't want to confuse Jesus
with that and with that
debate and that ongoing dialogue and so on.
I just want to identify him with a few of
these values that I mentioned
earlier.
>> So Christian liberalism and political conservatism
aren't
necessarily mutually exclusive.
SCOTTY McLENNAN: Correct.
There are Christian liberals who take what
we would call politically
conservative stance on issues like the size
of government, on
individualism, on the importance of private
property, all of the rest
of that.
And in my own denomination, the Unitarian
Universalist, which is
considered a very theologically liberal denomination
and it has had
quite honestly a lot of liberal political
action that's been taken in
our name as well, there are a number of us
who are you'd say a
libertarian and in that sense very conservative
about these basic
values.
[PAUSE]
>> Well, it's too tall.
Can you describe the Biblical support you
have for your position on
abortion?
SCOTTY McLENNAN: Can I describe the Biblical
support for my position
on abortion?
My position, can I do this quickly?
My position on abortion is that if we look
scripturally at this issue,
Jesus says nothing about abortion whatsoever.
And in Jesus' time, the notion was that a
fetus was not a human being,
was not an a DOM, an Adam.
It goes back to some Old Testament, Hebrew
Bible scripture about a
woman being hit in the stomach and losing
her fetus.
What is the response to that?
And the response is that person who does that
must pay a fine.
There's nothing about that being murder or
that having been a human
being, et cetera.
And the rabbis in the Talmud use that as a
basis for explaining that we
don't become an a DOM, we don't become an
human being until we're born.
It's the breath of life, the term "rua spirit"
47:27, that once we take
that first breath in the world, then we become
a human being, an Adam,
a person.
And you'll see even the Supreme Court decision
Roe v. Wade that some of
that history is traced.
And the Catholic Church, not until the -- in
the late 1800s did they
think that abortion was problematic at least
in the early days because
there was a notion of ensoulment, when does
the soul enter the fetus?
And before that, there was no strictures against
that.
Similarly, in the common law, there were no
strictures against
abortion.
So this is a more modern conception that's
come, ironically, with
scientific evidence.
Now that from the time you join a sperm and
an egg, everything goes
from there.
And so if you've got to pick a time when personhood
begins or human
life begins, for many, conception seems like
a more obvious time than
birth.
But my -- my point is that lots of us religiously
-- for religious
reasons and with religious interpretations,
a number of Jews, and lots
of Christians, if we thought that fetuses
were human beings, I hope we
would stand up the way Catholic doctrine now
asks us to, and a lot of
evangelicals do to say it's equivalent to
infanticide.
And we don't human beings to be killed.
And so I understand that urge and I appreciate
why people feel that
way.
But they -- I ask them to also understand
my theological understanding
which I think is Biblically-based, is historically-based
and we're in
the pluralistic society, we should have the
right to choose based on
our own religious beliefs.
I'm worried that we're getting close to the
time that we need to move
out of this room.
One more question.
>> It's appropriate for the end.
From the end of the Bible the Book of Revelation,
makes all kinds of
fantastic images appear in people's heads
and is used as justification
for all sorts of terrible things that are
done or things that are
terrible that will be done unbelievers.
I come from the Lutheran tradition and Martin
Luther had very big
questions about whether Revelation should
be part of the Cannon or not.
Can you talk about how Revelations should
inform our understanding of
God in our modern world?
SCOTTY McLENNAN: So Revelation is an apocalyptic
writing after the
time of the destruction of the Temple in Jerusalem
in 70 A.D., many
people who would interpret it very politically
in terms what was going
on in Israel at the time and the hopes for
the end of the Roman Empire
and how that might come about and so on.
It's full of wonderful but potentially damaging
imagery.
It's a very engaging, um, story, if you will.
And it has been used in a wide variety of
ways to prophesied the coming
end of the world and there's many communities
which have sold all their
goods and on the basis on a sense of the end
time is tomorrow, and
they've found actually, didn't work that way.
A famous psychologist at Stanford, Leon Festinger,
came up with the
notion of cognitive dissonance, this psychological
things, by studying
one of these communities in the 19th century
who did everything because
they thought the end time was coming on a
certain date.
They sold all their goods, et cetera, and
then it didn't happen.
They set another date.
It didn't happen, and at some point, people
had to put together this
sense of reality which they thought was Biblically-based,
and what was
actually happening, and it created cognitive
dissonance was the term
that he used psychologically for that.
So Revelation is a book that you want to look
at.
What was its historical time and place?
Why was it written?
What's the basis of that imagery?
How literally should we take that imagery?
And so on.
But you're right, it's been used in quite
extraordinary ways.
Why would we emphasis so much this particular
apocalyptic gospel rather
than looking at -- this apocalyptic writing,
rather than looking at the
Gospels, the stories of Jesus told from a
number of different angles
and what he did and how he lived and what
we taught us to do as human
beings.
That's what often confusing to me.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]